finally I understand that you're set to
play in the next Deadpool movie and even
though your character Logan or Wolverine
was killed off in the last movie You're
Gonna Play Wolverine again for the tenth
time yeah why I mean you categorize it
as the Deadpool movie we like to call it
Wolverine 10.
in our house
um can you check with Ryan Reynolds on
those yeah I don't need to check with
him I'm kidding
um we basically this is taking place
this story is pre Logan which is exactly
as you said where Logan died so we pray
that in the storyline okay
um and I honestly Chris I really thought
I was done like I was at peace with it
if I had I got asked every day either in
interviews or Ryan Reynolds or anything
can we do it again I'm like no I'm done
um someone said to me I think it was I
think it was Deb I think it was my wife
she said you know after this what is it
you really want to do and I was just
driving down a day later and I thought
what do I want and it came to me like
that because when I keep thinking of me
and Ryan of Deadpool and Wolverine which
are classic comic book Rivals there's
also a dynamic that I've never really
got to do before is Wolverine but
the music man is not Wolverine and with
all due respect and after this interview
affection Hugh Jackman at 54 is not Hugh
Jackman at 32. so how are you going to
get in that kind of shape I have I've
learned
you can't rush it
I've learned that
it takes time so we have six months from
when I finish to when I start filming
and I'm not doing any other work
I'm going to be with my family and train
that's going to be my job for six months
and I'm really fit right now there's one
thing that I chose a week being on
Broadway singing dancing is I'm fit so
I'm healthy I have a good place to start
and
apologies chickens run a mile start
running now because I'm coming